london 2012 olympics
uh one of the most dramatic
judo battles of all time
rematch yep so you've reached the
semifinals once again to face the german
holy bischoff
do you mind if we step through that
match a little bit
by all means
i've only ever watched the entire thing
one time just because
[ __ ]
so uh for context for the listener
um
travis first of all you don't like
losing
i think that's fair to say you know
the the hard part with this match is
because i went into this olympics
thinking
i'm not [ __ ] win the olympics i'm the
best in the world
i never in my right mind thought
oh i'm gonna win a medal like that never
that never crossed my mind
so it's like
i would have rather him just [ __ ]
beat me
yeah because then i lost
so here
the referees as as many people thought
robbed you of a victory but it was also
a really close battle again with sis
many of the elements of frustration as
2008 in terms of strategically and
gripping-wise
and it was just a fascinating battle
that went to overtime uh so
can you set the context so
what what did the bracket look like who
were the players here
um who did you beat leading up to this
match
like so as you walk onto the mat what
happened the day before the the hours
before as you're standing there but how
badass is it when two people are
standing like this
and yes [ __ ] that [ __ ] guy man
um but this this bracket um
was really interesting if you look at
like the backstory of 81 kilos like
leading up to the olympics right
because
at this point in time you know
i was inside the top ten at all times
you know eight seven five four
you know sixes i fell out of there
sometimes due to injuries but i always
climb back in
there was another guy
um
from azerbaijan
that was the olympic champion at 73
kilos in 2008
and
the entire division got rocked
by match one
because his first match was with antoine
vallis fortier of canada
and everybody who saw the draw come out
was like yarza bijani's going to win it
he's the former olympic champion he's
pretty much won most of the major events
including at 90 kilos because he just
had smooth judo
and
you know match one rolls around
match two rolls around antoine's in the
chute and he's looking around and he's
like
the azerbaijani is not here
well where is he
no joke he runs into the venue
a match before
throws his gui on and runs onto the
olympic platform
loses the canadian in like a
three-minute golden score battle
so do you think he warmed up
didn't he ran he literally
ran into the venue threw his gui on and
ran out didn't know judo
and there you see antoine
losing in the quarters
so how good was antoine
at this point in time this is i believe
his first international medal
was the olympic games
so i don't think he'd ever meddled in
paris
he went into this bracket unranked
beating the ranked guy
first round because he
i don't know if he missed the bus
i don't know if he was off his cycle and
planned on losing because he didn't want
to test positive i don't know
there's a lot of like
questionable things out there that could
have potentially
caused him to
you know
run onto the olympic platform for match
one
but
you know
it
it catapulted antoine into like a belief
that like
i beat the seated guy i'm i'm ready and
that was like a turning point in the
canadians career just as a whole
right that's that
everybody has a defining moment
like mine was when i beat bishop
uh in dusseldorf at the grand prix for
germany
after
right 2008.
beat the olympic champion in on his home
soil to go win the entire tournament so
we all have like those moments
it's just when it happens at the games
it throws the bracket like into a
tailspin because typically you know like
who's going to beat who where it's going
to happen
and when you look at my quarterfinal
against the brazilian
what most people don't know
is i was i was so thankful i had that
match most people would never in a
million years be like
i want to fight the world number one at
the olympic games that's what i want to
do i want to be the eighth seed fighting
the world number one because i'm gonna
win
i was pissed off at him i was so angry
because
we
were at the pan am's i think the year
before
and there was a team tournament and i
wanted to fight him i lost
the
quarters to a cuban i think in like the
first gripping exchange he threw me with
a drop sale out of nowhere i was pissed
so i wanted my hands on the brazilian in
the team match
well the brazilian team is warming up
so i walk up to him no joke i walked up
to him and i go
you're fighting and he goes
not today
and i went are you [ __ ] kidding me i
warmed up i taped up you're the only
[ __ ] guy i want to fight and you're
gonna [ __ ] sit in the stands and read
a goddamn book
i was so angry i carried that anger
because i never fought him until this
day
i was [ __ ] pissed i was ready to beat
him that's right i remember i forgot he
was uh the world number one yeah how did
um because i remember like being really
excited at that match how did you beat
him i threw him with two hands on the
same side collar yeah like dropped sail
i cross gripped i yanked him behind me
and i threw him ippon was ari and then
the match ended
30 seconds later yeah
i was pumped
i was i thought well i think okay if i'm
remembering correctly i thought okay
this guy might actually win
gold
that's that's what made for me as a
spectator remembering now
the next match that much more like
painful and then the fans of judo that
really followed the sport
the stats when you look at the games and
my draws i had the worst possible draw
as you ever could have imagined
at both london and rio i fought the
world number one
to get to the final or into the semis or
past the semis
and everybody i fought in the draw
either beat me the last time we fought
or i had never fought before
so i always held a loss going on to the
mat at the olympic games how'd you feel
about that by the way like what were
your feelings about facing the brazilian
first i was so excited this well that
was match three
in london i fought the slovenian guy
first round who beat me
um where'd he beat me was it the worlds
might have been the worlds and then
churches philly i fought in the second
round who threw me for wasari in japan
and then
leandro who i don't think i ever fought
who was world number one that avoided
fighting me
at the team tournament but i mean every
single olympics you've fought you really
stepped up the only tournament i've ever
prepped for
mentally and physically and just the
whole thing yeah
we never trained through this tournament
like we did for the others or
i would go into it injured all right
well let's talk about you're standing
there next to that uh
to the german he looks he looked always
smaller than you but you said like
strong yeah
uh so what are you feeling now jimmy
pedro behind you i was [ __ ] ready to
take his head off
did you have an idea of what you're
going to do did you try to do you're
thinking of winning by epon were you
thinking like going for big throws take
or take him in deep waters i'll grip him
or what were you thinking we were about
to have a battle and
i wasn't gonna throw him until he broke
mentally
okay
that was
there was no like oh this is gonna be a
clean throw that was never that was
never the thought process
so
so here
you know there's going to be a lot of
gripping so we're seeing a [ __ ] ton of
gripping
and right here he throws it bang
close-fisted
you got a lot of adrenaline you seem
calm i'm pissed you're pissed like you
don't look here you just look like i'm
well i'm looking at the ref like because
he keeps telling me to get up i'm like i
have blood running down my face
i go
okay
here see blood see he's like oh yeah go
fix it and that's on your eyebrow
somewhere yeah he split it just
underneath it so you split your eyebrow
and so in judo they don't they're
allergic to blood
probably for a good reason but they so
now you have to try to figure out
how to uh tape that up yeah
which already sets up one of the most
badass
looks in judo history
first 15 seconds yeah busted my eye open
was that getting in the way of your
eyesight at all or no no
damn he looks good at gripping how
difficult is it to get a grip on that
guy very
like i'm struggling just to get my hand
in the collar and he wasn't even
blocking it is he being caged yeah
remember like
is he interested in offense nope he's a
very cagey
you know methodical player like he he
never opens himself up yeah
there you go you grab the leg as part of
a combination yep
and people have told me that he's
actually very good at throwing people he
just doesn't
so but he just doesn't show it at these
no because he
he doesn't care how he wins he cares
that he wins
yeah which makes him very difficult to
beat
because he knows when you've strategized
to do that
where you look at the rule set and you
develop a plan to to get through the
matches then
you've really got to figure out a way to
get that person off that game plan you
know whether you get ahead by a penalty
or something
right there
like
he wouldn't give me the sleeve so i
grabbed all of his fingers
oh nice
in which is open
like to like this way or i grabbed them
the other way and i started lifting them
uh yeah
nice oh first plane like mercy like this
yeah
oh this is great because he wouldn't
give me the sleeve and i needed an
attack
and i'm like okay i can't hold on to
this forever because that judge is going
to see it so let me just do a quick
throw here while i'm using the fingers
and then you're just holding on yeah
and then i just sit out
and then yeah he goes to get up and i go
to get on top and right here
nice that elbow you get him oh you got
him yeah it looks like i elbow him
did you do it kind of no i didn't i at
the time i never knew this happened yeah
until after i watched this like three or
four years later
didn't even know i didn't even feel it
look at that so he's legitimately angry
here yeah he's angry
and of course you can't you can't move
why would you do this look at this this
moment right there is gold if you're not
watching this on video you're missing
out you do you never get this in judo no
i don't know if that's ever happened
that little face-off especially on a
stage like this the reference and then
he brings us in to like talk to us and
he's like hey we're good right like you
guys aren't about to do what i think
you're about to do
oh you put up here it's like hey shake
hands again because the first time we
did it that wasn't good enough well you
got to do it again
the heartbreaking part about this and
why the ijf switched it to an unlimited
golden score
because we fought five minutes
um
through the entire
normal part of the match and then we did
the entire
overtime period of three minutes not one
penalty was given
no gripping infractions zero false
attacks like no stalls great there was
that nobody was really backing up yep i
mean it was you know so what was jimmy
telling you here
how was he was he talking to you at all
he's not allowed to talk during medical
things and my nose is now broken
but he's also oh the nose is broken from
what um i caught an elbow from him
glad his face is clean that's fun
and right here like i was pissed i was
so angry at the medic because he's
fumbling around and i'm like my whole
plan is to break the german mentally
yeah you gotta hurry up with the tape
man like he's supposed to be tired like
he's not supposed to be resting
and is jimmy yelling here he can't
no not here not here but during the
match yeah and you can see i just take
it from him and i'm like give it to me
i'm going to do it myself get out of
here
how scared is the medic
it's like this guy can't even tear the
tape
look how nervous he is
[Laughter]
we made fun of him for this so much
throughout the years
still due to this day all right here we
go oh you look great get out here
can't really see don't care
was there some outcome in your mind that
you could possibly beat him on the
ground with a submission or a pin you
knew you're gonna have to throw him i
knew i was gonna have to if i was gonna
throw him or armbar him or pin him
whatever the case may be
it was gonna be his mental like
i'm just tired of this yeah right he's
too cagey of a player he's too
experienced
you know he has to mentally make that
choice to give that inch
and then you just have to be ready to
take it
so i was just waiting for it
and so now this is four minutes in one
minute left yeah okay oh
um is that in your game plan two
potential likes soon engaged like these
sacrifice throws to
because the whole point of that that
technique and the sacrifice throws
wasn't because i thought i was gonna
throw him
but
it disrupts the pattern enough to like
get him to make a potential mistake yeah
like see he should have gotten ashito
there
hands in the face
but again that's just part of judo yeah
he poked me in the eyeball
this is a rough match
it does he act at all or no like was he
acting frustrated or anything like that
it was all
like he's like acting for the ref you
know what i mean like oh that all that
kind of stuff you're just going in yeah
hard non-stop yeah like angry aggressive
feeling cardio here at all like i don't
i'm not tired during this
and then we're just always pressing
forward time runs out
now we're into golden score 12 minutes
and 38 seconds later
yeah you think about every judo exchange
right every time we grip up every time
we attack sometimes it can take longer
to get back to the line than the entire
exchange yeah
so the the more aggression the more
exchanges you have the the the longer
the time stretches
then here the six seconds left and
golden score
your tape
there's uh
there's no
yellow and red yeah
with sweat and blood literally and time
is out now what are you thinking here do
you think you won the match
i i thought i won the match a minute ago
i remember thinking to myself like if
this goes to the flags
i won
no doubt in my mind
because
i felt like the whole time like i was
going to him
yeah right he was never coming at me
yeah that's the way it felt
i think like
that's the way it felt body
language-wise just the intensity how
fast you're moving towards him you're
constantly going for throws
now if you want to rewind that we can
talk about the whole because it's a part
of this clip so wait wait a minute uh
they all went blue they all did so in
judo there's three referees two on the
side one in the center and they all vote
and now let's pause it right there now
the way this is supposed to work they
raise their flags they do like a one two
count and then on three they all raise
it together yeah now as a little pretext
to this entire match
up until this point
not one match at the olympic games has
ever been a split decision
meaning out of three people
not one of them voted against the other
group members
so they were all unified blue or all
unified white yeah right which is um
statistically difficult to imagine yes
it's almost like the they had a referee
meeting and said um it's better for the
olympics to never have a split yeah
okay
so the question becomes
if you click that frame by frame
right so right now we have all the refs
with their flags out
and then click that so the middle
middle guy is
he is all the way up all the way up the
other side judges haven't moved we now
have one side raft all the way up
then we have a third side ref
all the way up
yeah so there there's a the time point
when the middle guy has the flag all the
way up if not 80 90 of the way there
yeah then the other one does
and then the third one goes
uh so now the question becomes who
really
like did the outside reps really have an
opinion
or were they told
to wait for the center one to start
and then
lift whatever flag the center ref picked
yeah this is very unfortunate because
it's very honestly it's very possible
that they had this meeting
um
this this is the problem with
the
the olympics they sometimes
it's also the problem in the soviet
union with communism you think the the
committee
knows what's good for the people and so
on so they decide
universally as opposed to letting the
magic of the olympics
be uh
be what it is but nevertheless
the in this case the center ref decided
blue
like what do you think
do you think it's just a shitty call
or
like
he has the right to pick but yeah the
problem is is
the other two i don't think did
yeah so
and then so when you do this frame by
frame again
right
like i can see from my own perspective
two of the refs
and i see them both blue
right so when you fast forward that a
little bit to get to like all the flags
i see the two go blue and i go
i look over and i look at the other guy
and i'm like
really
yeah all three
i've fought for eight minutes and i
can't even get a vote i didn't even get
a penalty
i can't even get a vote
and that's when i broke
i like oh
i couldn't believe it
and i'm not gonna lie he looks shocked
and here you're i'm just nice
you're crying literally you're right
yeah
but i think it's the end amazing match
that was such a war
i mean both people can't believe what
happened i know that's the and like
honestly i wish we had the rules that we
do today as far as the unlimited golden
score
because
i would have loved to have seen what
would have happened what was jimmy
saying here to you i mean i guess
there's nothing to say
yeah he
he was kind of apologizing for the way
the
the scores went because he knows how
badly you want it he saw the match and
he felt i deserve to win it yeah based
on like you know what happened but he
probably with all his experience knows
that this is what the olympics are about
the rest sometimes yep i mean that's the
magic of it man well and at the same
time we're at
we're in the olympic semi-final
in a sport that's dominated by certain
continents
and when you look at the three refs on
the mat
they're all european
yeah you're telling me there couldn't
have been one pan am one african one
oceana
you know different
like why'd they all have to be european
but to be fair
it's back to your sauna story
it's right you've dealt with this stuff
before and and you've won over this
stuff before and that's why like i was
broken and you thought you won here
those
and when i hindered on that for
[Music]
a year and a half like i couldn't even
stand i was done
but i'm pretty sure there's a
slow-motion replay on this when i watch
that he's all excited that [ __ ] guy
he's all happy he's relieved
hey hi guys
i did it
yeah so here's like teeth
slow motion
replay of the flags being raised the
heart being broken travis just spending
over right here watch watch his reaction
like
he like you could see his mouth like
open and aw like yeah really yeah and
he's looking at two refs just like i am
he didn't celebrate until he looked at
the third one and said oh all three
so you think he knew
i think in his head like
i don't think he really believed he was
winning he did it enough to win yeah
yeah
because when his mouth dropped like
oh yeah hey all three like
that's not really the reaction you would
give
yeah i mean that was um
that's one of the greatest matches i've
ever seen i mean obviously it's painful
for you but
that pain
first of all sets the stage for uh 2016
but even without that
i think it was just a beautiful story at
the olympics you've still did incredible
job at that olympics you stood toe
toe-to-toe
i think
in
in hindsight having
lost that match did more for me and more
for the sport
yeah as a whole me losing that match
yeah
i mean stories aren't about
winning stories are about the fighting
so and that made one hell of a story but
it it also has to do with
you know
treachery is probably not the right word
to use it's probably the
wrong word entirely to use but
because of the conflict in the match and
because of how the refs
handled the match there at the end
it created controversy that was spoken
about for
months on world media
right i remember articles being written
about the olympics and
you know the reffing and how it was
corrupt and that match was one of them
there was another one in fencing where
like something happened with the timer
where one of the fencers
i guess what happens in fencing the
timer
resets up a second
if it's down so the fencer got one
second played out i think like 27 or 28
times
and then one on like 30.
so like there was like
clock fixing for fencing there was this
match
that i think just got publicity good or
bad publicity is publicity for judo
you